gaétan barrette bonjour bonjour monsieur
barrette je me souviens aussi j'ai fait
une entrevue avec voir terrebonne dans
un centre commercial où vous étiez
candidat pour l'acaa qui en un an et
demi il vous me disiez beaucoup de mal
de monsieur couillard à l'époque de
monsieur bolduc pardon ministre la santé
vous étiez pas très ami avec les
libéraux comment ont pu le magazine et
c'est parti comme on magasine quoi un
restaurant ou une auto quoi vous changer
comme ça
expliquez moi alors moi je n'ai pas
magasiner et pour que ce soit clair pour
tous les auditeurs de takuya m'a
contacté et c'est un ce qui est un signe
ce qui est un signe de grand courage
alors moi j'étais dans une démarche qui
était personnelle qui avait fait en
sorte que j'avais annoncé que je ne
reviendrai pas en politique pour toutes
sortes de raisons et j'ai une approche
docteur couillard qui lui vous voulez
monter une équipe très forte en santé
mais c'est ce que vous avez aujourd'hui
très bien mais je suis non mais jusque
là dessus excusez moi vous dites ça
prenait du courage que vous voulez dire
c'est qu'effectivement vous n'aviez pas
beaucoup de bien à dire de l'époque
quand michel couillard et ministre la
santé je me trompe pas la garde et non
au contraire quand dr couillard était
milices de santé il y avait des choses
qui étaient très significative pour le
réseau de rappelez-vous de 6,3 et toutes
ces choses là alors il y avait des
choses qui étaient très difficiles à
faire ceci étant dit il faut faire
attention entre les déclarations que
tout un chacun peut faire selon leur
position respective à l'époque
couillard docteur bolduc et moi même
avons eu au fil du temps de nombreux
échanges sur les tod de notre réseau de
santé et des problèmes et pas des
problèmes et des remèdes qu'il y aurait
à y apporter
et là dessus on a toujours été d'un
commun accord maintenant les joutes du
passé ce sont les joueurs du passé
aujourd'hui on commence une campagne
électorale qui regarde vers le futur et
quand vous regardez ce qui est devant
vous là vous n'avez pas un seul parti
politique qui s'approche de notre
expertise très belle bêtise elle est là
moi je viens ajouter en plus une
détermination que tout le monde connaît
j'ai très content de le faire et dans 35
jours les gens auront à se positionner à
savoir est ce qu'on continue avec le
véhicule qui fait rien ou détériore le
système de santé et l'économie en
général
ou bien on voit que l'antarctique et
vente de faire les choses en présentant
à la campagne et je suis convaincu qu'à
la fin on aura un gouvernement il
françois legault écrit 1 ce matin sur
son compte twitter guetta barrettes de
lepoint prêt à tout pour être ministre
la santé peu importe le parti le
programme le chef etc
ça risque pas de vous coller à la peau
ça parce que vous vous êtes elle est la
guerre avec la cac avec monsieur legault
il est encore chef de l'acq est qu'en
passant
oui et mes premiers c'était les mêmes il
dit une 2011 les choses à moitié vrai
monsieur legault je la comprends je suis
prêt à tout pour servir la population je
lis toujours dit vous pouvez aller dans
le passé là mes déclarations là moi je
me suis toujours battu beaucoup notre
système de santé donne les services à la
population la population qui nous
écoutent là elle en a ras-le-bol et elle
s'attend à ce qu'à un moment donné il ya
quelqu'un qui a qui est la détermination
pour le faire le ya pas quelqu'un qui se
présente devant eux devant lui qu'il y
aura détermination mais une équipe est
en partie la campagne sa voiture
qu'est-ce qui est venu pour le québec
dans les 35 prochains jours dans les
landes l'isoloir
quand on va mettre notre 3e but n va le
pq qui nous amènera encore dans un
référendum
après avoir mal géré à peu près des bars
à coire québec où le parti libéral qui a
une vraie équipe vraiment compétents
vraiment déterminer qui est un programme
où il ya de la marchandise qui va être
livrée parce que quand vous verrez notre
programme c'est çà et là les gens vont
voir que oui c'est ça non mais je
comprends tous hommes se barrait je vous
avais le droit vous avez le droit de
changer d'idée peace corps est que vous
lui faites mais j'essaie de comprendre
ce que la caq a de différent par rapport
à il y en a une miss auf les sondages
qui sont plus bas et il y aura pas de la
voir pas du tout pas du tout encore une
fois là moi j'avais fait une croix là
dessus il y a une
une situation qui se présente qui me
permet de faire partie c'est une chose
qui était pas sur mon écran radar
et aujourd'hui on se retrouve avec quoi
on peut faire toutes sortes de procès
c'est correct c'est normal ça va être la
journée les électeurs
ceux qui nous écoutent ce qu'ils veulent
des résultats je pense qu'aujourd'hui
ils vont être bien content de voir ce
qu'ils ont devant eux en terme
d'équipement santé